c'est une tradition dans le monde de la
course depuis 10 ans chaque début
janvier des milliers de coureurs
investissent la petite commune de cerner
la ville juste après les fêtes de fin
d'année ce dimanche 7 janvier ces
sportifs venus de 61 départements et de
l'étranger viennent participer au
premier marathon et semi-marathon de
France au programme également un 10 km
un meeting de joelette un vrai succès
pour ce rendez-vous qui se déroule au
cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse on s'est
dit si on veut avoir du monde il faut
que maintenant les les creurs cherchent
un petit peu de s dans leur course à
pied cherche des défis et on sétait dit
ben si on fait ça au mois de mai juin on
aura pas grand monde par contre si on
fait ça tout de suite après les fêtes on
peut avoir du monde on a commencé avec
200 coureurs en 2014 et là pour les 10
ans on a refusé du monde et on a bloqué
à 1600 personnes dans le froid et sous
la grisaille le semi-marathon a été
remporté chez les hommes par Gaspar
fondbonne en 1h 13 minutes et 31
secondes chez les féminines Carole
Stéphan 4e en 2023 remporte cette
fois-ci l'épreuve 2024 ça c'est très
très bien passé mieux que je pensais à
part le vent en fait qui qui ralentit
beaucoup évidemment et un peu de froid
au départ mais sinon super du côté du
marathon plus de 400 courageux ont pris
le départ de l'épreuve cette année chez
les féminines garant sperro s'impose en
3h 4 minutes et 36 secondes chez les
hommes la course a été remportée par le
villepreusien Nicolas duil en 2h 41
minutes et 5 secondes les Vinois s'impos
pour la deuxième fois consécutive sur
l'épreuve bah on m'ait on m'ait donné le
dosin 1 donc que j'avais un peu la
pression parce que j'ai gagné l'année
dernière mais c'est jamais gagné
d'avance tir en marathon parce que c'est
c'est quand même long donc on sait pas
comment réagir les jambes mais ça s bien
passé donc je suis content une 11e
édition est déjà programmée pour l'année
prochaine elle sera organisée cette
fois-ci le 5 janvier